many are inquiring how am i to
make the surrender of myself to god
you desire to give yourself to him but you
are weak in moral power in slavery to doubt
and controlled by the habits of your life of sin
your promises and resolutions are like ropes
of sand you cannot control your thoughts your
impulses your affections the knowledge of your
broken promises and forfeited pledges weakens
your confidence in your own sincerity and
causes you to feel that god cannot accept you
but you need not despair what you need to
understand is the true force of the will this
is the governing power in the nature of
man the power of decision or of choice
everything depends on the right action of the
will the power of choice god has given to men
it is theirs to exercise you cannot
change your heart you cannot of yourself
give to god its affections but you can choose
to serve him you can give him your will
he will then work in you to will and to do
according to his good pleasure thus your
whole nature will be brought under the control
of the spirit of christ your affections will be
centered on him your thoughts will be in harmony
with him desires for goodness and holiness are
right as far as they go but if you stop here
they will avail nothing many will be lost
while hoping and desiring to be christians they do
not come to the point of yielding the will to god
they do not now choose to serve him through the
right exercise of the will an entire change may
be made in your life by yielding up the will to
christ you ally yourself with the power that is
above all principalities and powers you will have
strength from above to hold you steadfast and thus
through constant surrender to christ you will be
unable to live the new life even the life of faith